رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي السابق أهود
باراك، جنرال في الجيش، رئيس سابق للقوات
المسلحة، ومرحبًا بعودتك إلى
برنامجنا، ومن الجيد حقًا أن تكون
معنا لأنه من الواضح أننا نريد أن
نفهم من وجهة نظرك الفريدة
كيف ستبدو الأيام القادمة
وكيف ستبدو  الهدف من
التوغل العسكري أو هذا
الرد العسكري على حماس في
غزة أه كان أشد ضربة أه تلقتها
إسرائيل طوال
وجودها فشل كبير في
عملية استخباراتية تصل إلى
القيادة السياسية العليا وأه الآن لدينا
أولا  ليتأكد أن حماس
ستتلقى الضربة المناسبة التي يجب أن
يتلقاها لكي يكون تكرار مثل هذا
الحدث ح مستحيلا وأه
لا يتم دون
المخاطرة الأكيدة بتوسيع الدائرة إلى الشمال
وكذلك الطوبة في  في الشمال أو إلى
بعض الخلايا النائمة في يهودا والسامرة،
كل شيء يمكن أن يحدث، ولا يمكنك التنبؤ به،
فتفاصيل أي خطة سيتم تحديدها
بتفاصيل غير قابلة
للمناقشة عبر التلفزيون. إسرائيل
عازمة على التأكد من
محاسبة أم حماس.  على هذا
الهجوم البربري القاتل أم آه، ماذا عن
الرهائن كيف يمكنك أن تفعل ذلك في
نفس الوقت، هل يجب على المرء أن
يحدث أولاً ما هي تلك
الاستراتيجية، إنها قضية حساسة للغاية
بالطبع تضع
قيودًا معينة على الاعتبارات ولكن
أعتقد ذلك  لن يكون من الذكاء
مشاركة هذه الفروق الدقيقة الجديدة بيني وبينك
على شاشة التلفزيون لأننا لسنا وحدنا
من يستمع إليها ولا
أعتقد أنها قد تكون موضوعًا
للمناقشة، لذا اسمح لي  اطلب التقييد ولكن
سيتعين علينا أن نتدبر أمورنا، لذا دعني أسألك
إذن ما مدى احتمالية
بقاء الرهائن على قيد الحياة؟ ما هو السبب في رأيك
لأخذ هذا العدد الكبير من الرهائن؟ ما هو
السبب الاستراتيجي لفعل حماس ذلك؟
ماذا يريدون منك؟  لا، إنه
عدد غير مسبوق من الأشخاص الذين
تعلمون أن نجاحهم تجاوز توقعاتهم بكثير
وأعتقد أن الهدف بالطبع هو
إطلاق سراح جميع سجنائهم ربما يكون
10000 منهم أه في السجناء الإسرائيليين
ليتم إطلاق سراحهم و  سيحاولون
دفعها نحو نهايتها، ليس من
الواضح كيف ستنتهي، فإذا كنت أنت
وأنت تعلم أن إسرائيل دخلت
هذه الرهائن الأحادية أو غير المتوازنة
أه التبادل أه بجلعاد شال
كان هناك 1100 أو نحو ذلك من الفلسطينيين المفرج عنهم
هؤلاء كثيرون جدًا
بعامل كبير، هل ستطلق سراح جميع
السجناء مقابل
هذه النظرة؟ أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنه من
المحتمل أن ثلثهم أه لديهم أيضًا جواز
سفر أجنبي، وبعضهم
أجانب حقيقيون حقًا مثل بعض
العمال  من تايلاند، آخرون لديهم جواز سفر أمريكي
أو بريطاني أو أوروبي أو
دول أخرى. أفترض أنهم
سيكونون على استعداد لإطلاق سراحهم
بشروط معينة، لكن حتى ذلك الحين
سيكون لديهم ما يكفي من الرهائن
للتفاوض بقوة شديدة من أجل إطلاق سراح
جميع الأشخاص و  أنا حقا
لا أعتقد أنه سيكون من الذكاء بالنسبة
لي أن أناقش معك